all right next up if you're a writer but
not quite as prolific as stephen king we
might have a new way for you to get
those tip and type of thinkers going
through our list reports there's a new
cafe in japan designed just for writers
they got free wi-fi plenty of outlets to
plug in bottomless coffee but there's
one teeny tiny catch you are not allowed
to leave until you finish riding all
right and you'll be charged a dollar
twenty for every half an hour that you
need extra motivation and you stay there
yeah you can only leave after you've
finished your writing goal for the day
or when the cafe closes at seven
whatever comes first
i will say i've written a couple books
you've written a couple of books it is
so difficult to do because you are your
own boss it's on you to like sit down
and do it and clock in and finish and
i'm like the best boss because i would
sit down and be like boss can i have a
five minute break and i'd be like yes
you can and then i go
you have to
think of this cafe i think it's great
because it gives you the structure you
need when you're artists you don't
you're not used to a nine to five and so
this gives you a reason to get in there
stay and a goal to finish structure and
accountability raise of hands
who thinks this idea is good and should
come stateside
i double with you ma'am what is your
name
caroline i am so with you with the
double hands out of curiosity why are we
enthusiastically putting up two hands i
know why for me but why for you
because you need that accountability to
just get stuff done i'm with you russ
i'll do the five minute break okay
sometimes i give myself a 10 minute
break too you know what i mean whatever
i need why not make some microwave
salmon while you're at it well
caroline
it wasn't bad but i'm not saying that
caroline in true writing fashion
informed you just paid the earlier story
off yeah thank you for that bookend
thank you i love this idea so much and
whatever company is doing this please
come all over the world i i just love
this this is a a great story to me do it
totally i want more i am i'm writing a
third book i know i know and i'm like
rossi whoa we haven't talked about that
i'm ready i'm writing now
hello cookbook i'm working on recipes
yes i know
[Applause]
this is um
this the world is right with the recipes
book because that's been a thing for you
for a long time it's it's due it's how i
lost you know 60 pounds and kept it off
cooking for myself and really trying to
figure out food and be healthy and be
good
but i will tell you as inspired as i am
to write this book i am like i need a
break so this is i i need this i needed
to hear this story today so thank you
drew for bringing this up i'm i'm glad
you liked it thank you oh and here's
what i have for you we have a little
woodworker in england making a really
big difference i love this story people
reports 12 year old gabriel clark has
always loved woodworking and he's a hit
on instagram selling handmade cutting
boards and bowls to save up money to buy
a bike how great is that but now
he's doing something else amazing he's
raffling off a special custom bowl for
ukrainian children yeah
and proceeds we love this they're going
to go to save the children
and get this gabriel has already raised
327
dollars
woodworking
it's
wow
incredible
he is such a lovely human being i think
his work is really beautiful
yeah and what a heart and soul in this
beautiful human being and um speaking of
supporting ukraine we want to shout out
to our partners at pluto tv actually you
can catch us on pluto tv anytime on the
drew barrymore show channel
and
you can check out their ads for change
campaign because they're running free
ads to get the support for incredible
organizations doing work on the ground
in ukraine save the children world
central kitchen unhcr and the
international rescue committee so if you
want to help and you're looking for a
place to start because that's a huge
part of it it's just where do i start
these are great groups to go and support
and you can get all the information on
our website and i always say to like one
dollar five dollars that's it one of
these places it will make a difference
[Applause]
[Music]
you